the Joe Rogan experience he's gonna come
out in a certain stance like a look you
know his little karate style yeah and
then he was gonna actually do I don't
know what he was but he was freaking out
and I was just like that the thing about
Marlon is Marlon is a giant 135 yeah I
mean Marlon is so big I don't know how
much weight he cuts but I know the
californian won't let him fight 135
again because California has that rule
where you can't hydrate more than I
think it's ten percent or so you can't
ya blow back up you can't blow back up
so he did blow back up in a fight in
California had no more 135 for you cuz
so it's very obvious that he's cutting a
tremendous amount of weight he's huge
he's huge like a comic book character
yeah he is so I think that he cut way
too much weight and I think that that
that contributes to his demise in the
second round because he couldn't take
Henry out he just he knew his locker he
needs
Yanni's like it's ten knees in a row
what was ridiculous and he didn't he let
him clinch with him like that in a way
that you don't do unless you're tired
and it just I think he compromises
himself I think there's two things going
on one I think Henry has a force of will
that very few few human beings can ever
possibly understand I mean Henry has a
self belief and and just in a stainless
steel will that [ __ ] just puts
it on you and I think Marlin outclassed
him in that first round but I don't
think it's sustainable I don't think he
can keep that pace with that dehydration
level and with with what he's doing to
his body to make 135 pounds I think he
cripples so what does the division go
now since Henry is out here's the
problem if he goes to 145 right if
Marlin goes to 145 then he doesn't
maintain the same advantages that he has
in cutting all that weight then he's the
size of these guys okay so he goes to
140 just think about guys like Calvin
cater that can that flattened rind you
know crack flat line yeah and he's tall
and long and that [ __ ] is not gonna work
on him the way it works on those 135
pound guys
[Applause]